les qui gloussent découvre que l'eau
mais pas toujours de tout repos des
apprend avec hull a profité de l'eau en
toute sécurité
on est en pleine semaine de la sécurité
aquatique est ce que vous voyez
actuellement c'est la capsule mission
plouffe s'est mise en ligne dans la zone
jeunesse de radio canada en
collaboration avec la société de
sauvetage a pour rappeler aux enfants
les consignes de sécurité bien sûr
toujours dans le but d'éviter les
noyades reynaldo reprise de la société
sauvetage avec moi ce matin bonjour et
non bonjour à vous il faut rappeler tout
d'abord qui a déjà eu 12 noyade au
québec depuis le début de l'année c'est
plus que ce qu'on avait l'année passée à
pareille date
oui mais enfin compte lorsqu'on regarde
un petit plus nos données on s'aperçoit
que l'année dernière faisaient beaucoup
plus beau alors donc on avait
sensiblement un nombre de noyades un
petit peu plus similaire par rapport au
week-end si je regarde le premier
week-end du mois de juin les données qu
on a mis en ligne c'était celle de
vendredi
alors on est dans à peu près dans les
mêmes eaux sans faire de jeu de mots
mais il reste que pour nous noie yade
c'est toujours une de trop et quand même
12 moyenne alors que la vraie saison la
baignade n'est toujours pas commencé
c'est sûr qu'on a en tête ses deux
enfants deux événements distincts au
printemps là des enfants qui ont été
poussés à l'eau par un autre enfant
j'imagine que ça faisait remarquer très
fortement oui très fortement parce que
c'est certainement pas le résultat qu'on
souhaite ça arrive
nous on le voit dans les lieux de
baignade de telles que piscine publique
c'est écrit on ne bouscule pas on ne
pousse pas parce qu'on pense plutôt que
c'est la blessure à la moelle épinière
dans la partie peu profonde face à la
noyade le fait de se retrouver dans une
partie profonde nécessairement ça nous a
interpellé beaucoup
et de rappeler aux enfants ce message de
sécurité l'a d'ailleurs on a avisé
l'ensemble des motards qui font le
programme nager pour survivre à l'effet
de pouvoir dire justement voulez vous
ajoutez cette règle de sécurité lors
qu'on puisse bien comprendre que c'est
pas juste la partie peu profonde mais
aussi le risque de noyade qu'on peut
on peut avoir comme résultat on s'était
vus il ya quelques semaines d'ailleurs
vous nous aviez parlé de ce programme
nager pour survivre en lien avec la
sortie du livre de sylvie bernier et
puis vous nous aviez dit que c'est un
programme pour les enfants de 8 ans et
plus donné dans les écoles pour que les
enfants apprennent quoi faire en eau
vivres surtout en partie profonde aussi
mais là vous allez le modifier quand
même ce programme la raison le succès
passe justement parce que les règles de
sécurité qu'on voit dans ce programme là
c'est toujours dangereux qu'un emmy
l'importance de porter la veste de
flottaison regarder avant de plonger et
on la borde la sécurité sur glace alors
on va ajouter justement cette notion-là
de on ne bouscule pas on ne pousse pas
une personne surtout pas plus dans la
partie peu profonde que dans la partie
profonde parce qu'il ya des risques qui
y sont associés malheureusement on ne
veut pas que de tels drames peut se
reproduire à nouveau je regardais les
chiffres de la croix rouge ce matin à
liées à la sécurité aquatique on
rappelle que 75 % des noyades dans les
piscines qui surviennent alors qu'il n'y
a pas de surveillance d'adultes
surveillance parentale ce que c'est
exactement ce que vous voyez aussi nous
ce qu'on voit c'est tout plan d'eau
confondues ont ni plus près de neuf fois
sur 10 où il n'y avait pas de
supervision par rapport aux enfants leur
fait que ça peut inclure la baignoire à
la maison ça peut inclure aussi les
piscines résidentielles où il arrive
lorsqu'on pense au chalet
majoritairement la noyade chez les
enfants est au jour a déçu même des
parents de là l'importance de pouvoir
leur applique tu peux pas aller à l'eau
sans la présence de leur papa comme on
dit tu veux pas déjoué dans la rue tout
seul quand tu peux pas te laisser les
rues du seul alors c'est la même
consigne qu'on doit donner en eau a
rappelé aux enfants mais rappelé à aux
adultes aussi absolument et surtout pas
prendre pour acquis que le grand frère
ou la grande soeur peut assumer cette
surveillance klaus la noyade chez un
enfant c'est un phénomène de 15 à 20
secondes
c'est de façon très silencieux très
silencieux comme situation
alors donc c'est ce qui fait qu'il faut
revenir à la charge
particulièrement début de saison c'est
le temps d'aller re vérifier s'ils
n'obtenaient bien aménagé toujours
cadenassé ou tout le moins que l'accès à
la piscine
vraiment fixe la de ce côté là et par la
suite lorsqu'on va pouvoir voir une
belle température pouvoir se baigner
comprendra qu'on dira aux enfants tu
peux pas aller te baigner sans la
présence de maman ou papa oui voilà
c'est ça et quand on regarde c'est la
belle saison va finir par arriver là on
va finir par se baigner il faut rappeler
à quel point c'est important de porter
la veste de flottaison aussi quand on
veut aller sur un plan d'eau on a sorti
les statistiques de la société de
sauvetage et reina qui nous rappelle que
soixante dix huit pour cent des victimes
qui ne portent pas de veste de
flottaison 87% sont disent oui plus
souvent qu'autrement ce soit plus belle
à la témérité ça m'arrivera pas pour sa
vie on a fait un sondage à travers tout
le canada pour vérifier pourquoi des
gens n'apportez pas cette veste de
flottaison là c'est parce qu'ils n'ont
pas l'intention de se retrouver par
dessus bord alors ce matin jamais les
tensions oui mais ce matin quand je me
suis attaché sa ceinture dans mon auto
mon avenir ici c'est pas parce que
j'avais l'intention d'avoir un accident
c'est ce que je sais que c'est que si
jamais ça arrive pour faire la
différence et si ce qui nous amène à
dire tout le temps si les gens prenaient
le temps de la porte et s'il y aurait
des anecdotes à raconter
puis encore lahlou est encore très
froide à cette période ci de l'année
un choc thermique peut amener même une
inconscience dual une hyperventilation
que l'eau froide bonou offert à réagir
au volant on les voit les fameux
chiffres donc au milieu 87% elles sont
des hommes et 69 % des noyades ont lieu
dans un lac ou une rivière puis l'alcool
qui est un facteur de risque encore
présent bien présent dans 30 % des cas
on a là rien dit merci beaucoup d'elle
une fois ce matin le plaisir sur 20